[Applause]
hours
Jimmy Jimmy hey everybody I am Jimmy
Fallon I am in for Greg Gutfeld and I'd
just like to say before we start if you
do like my jacket it also comes in men's
for those of you who don't know me
watching at home I am a former New York
City cab driver and the truth is I'm
actually lucky to be alive because the
driving in this town is psychotic New
York is the only city in the world where
you signal after you've already made it
into the next Lane
anywhere else in America if you want to
go left you put on your blinker like hey
I'm going left but if you do that here
they block you
so instead you have to go left then you
put on your blinker like haha oh I made
it
but the other thing you need to know
about me is I grew up in an era where
late night comedy was something the
whole country could share that's what
life was in the 1980s every regular
person could share late night and every
celebrity could share Madonna
um
if you didn't laugh at that it's because
it burns when you pee but stick with me
so tonight what I'm going to try to do
is I'm going to try to unite the country
with some basic truths I think we should
all be able to agree on and I know not
all of you are going to love it but you
need to remember these are just jokes if
you don't like something I say you don't
have to get angry and hold up the show
uh you can email me afterwards at
kissmyass.com
um
because this is the thing nobody cares
jokes are in hate crimes and we even
learned that when Kathy Griffin showed
us that horrible plastic face and
afterwards she held up Trump's head
afterwards
folks the point is comedy is supposed to
be treated like a buffet if you see a
joke you like you throw it on your tray
if you don't like the joke you don't
stop the line and argue with the chef
like oh no you didn't you know what I
mean you move on to the next item we all
get our own tray because the truth is
it's not just Comics everybody in the
world is having a hard time with speech
police one of my best friends just moved
over to London and he was telling me the
other day you can't even call a wussy a
wussy over there you have to call them
Prince Harry
and of course I bring up the Royals why
because they're a rare point of unity in
our country the truth is whether you're
black white asian Muslim Latino deep
down we all want the same thing which is
for Meghan Markle to shut the up
hear me
Jimmy
but think about it we're living in an
America where 70 percent of the country
is living paycheck to paycheck nobody
wants to hear about the difficulties of
being a princess you tone deaf idiot so
here's what I would say Magister if
you're going to keep talking at least
make it interesting and do a true crime
podcast about how you stole Prince
Harry's balls
and I'm just being honest with her and
I'm being honest with you because nobody
else will big Tech censors the truth all
the time the White House hides
everything they said they'd be the most
transparent Administration in history
but please Joe Biden thinks transparent
is a man who has a baby
everybody in DC they just lie they tell
you student loan forgiveness is a thing
but the loans aren't forgiven they're
just passing the bill on to other people
and to be clear I'm not even worried
about paying for college because my son
is six foot five he's getting a women's
basketball scholarship
[Applause]
Jimmy
yeah you guys are saving up for school
I'm saving them for a backboard and
probably a little duct tape you know
what I'm saying
sorry link man but here is the deal
we're going soft in this country can't
even beat your kids anymore so they
don't have to respect us and I'm not
telling you I want to beat my kid but
the fact that my kid knows I can't beat
him is a problem you dig you ever get so
mad at your kid you wonder if you could
survive in prison
like if I get through a month I could
smack this little bastard right here in
Target
and the whole concept that is so foreign
to me because I'm Italian which means
not only did I get beat as a kid but my
parents used weapons okay every Italian
kid got beat with either a belt or a
spoon that's how it went down and that
wasn't a messed up part the messed up
part was you had to go get it for them
do you know how traumatic it is to go
get an inanimate object that you know is
going to destroy your life
it's the closest thing to buying an
engagement ring I can explain to you
Jimmy stomp it my wife and I were
actually married 16 years this year 16
years oh you got it
we're actually in an awkward spot
because the last three times we went to
the grocery store we ran into my high
school girlfriend
weird yeah but it's going to change
because she's going to graduate but uh
[Laughter]
Jimmy
but here's the thing and I'm telling you
this because I care someone invented a
time machine the best thing you could do
for society would be to put today's kids
in it and dial 1982. you know that
people come walking out in someone's
living room all sassy complaining about
everything a VCR I'm not watching a VCR
mommy it takes a little day I am not
watching some power just throw a shoe
across the living room shut up you know
do you is this like a symposium for
abused kids I'm sorry if that one hit
home a little bit
but do you remember when George Bush was
your president he was over in Iraq
someone threw a shoe at him and he
dodged it that's because he got beat as
a kid
[Laughter]
that's what I learned in that moment
Barbara Bush was a shoe thrower back in
the day
20 years from now someone throws a shoe
with the president he's getting smoked
because he won't know how to dodge it
you understand except they won't throw a
shoe they'll throw a Snickers bar and
they'll die of a peanut allergy
the point I'm trying to make is tough
times call for tough measures and if
we're going to turn this country around
we need to dish out some tough love and
I know it sounds risky in an age of
incentivized outrage but I'm still all
about it because the truth is it takes
balls for a man to get ahead in 2023 and
if we're being honest it takes balls for
a woman too
[Applause]
Jimmy
let's welcome tonight's guest she is
making her debut on the show but don't
worry because when you talk about the
best female comics in the country she
has watched all of them uh comedian and
problem Drinker My Pal Ali Breen there
she is Alex
she has spent more time completing other
people's sentences than Jill Biden
editor-in-chief of the Federalist Molly
Hemingway in the house there it is
foreign
he's dated so many guys he's about to
get transferred to another Parish author
of the book so you've been sent to
diversity training Chadwick Moore Hey
Girl
she's like a nor'easter people freak out
72 hours before she even shows up Fox
News contributor and author Captain
there it is
Chad we're coming to start with you you
and I spend a lot of money to get
spanked as adults yeah but should we at
least thank more as kids yeah yeah uh
let's see I was um my mom smacked me
with a bag of frozen waffles once when I
was a kid that was the best
so you're the only guy who has egos in
his search history unlike YouPorn yeah
yeah
screwed with me exactly yeah
that's funny cat you wrote an amazing
book about speech being an equivalent of
violence in the minds of some people and
I'm not just saying amazing because you
gave me 50 bucks
um stick with me though for real do you
think there are people out there who
don't know the difference between speech
and violence or are people feigning
ignorance because it comes with some
type of political leverage I think for
it depends I think in a lot of cases
it's because uh it does come with the
leverage uh because if you're going to
accuse somebody okay so look in my book
you can't joke about that available
whatever books are sold
um I talk about how in another book The
Bible like one of the least chill books
in there is Leviticus that's like not a
chill book that's the eye for an eye uh
but we're even stricter than Leviticus
when it comes to jokes because nobody
could honestly tell you that the worst
thing that ever happened to them was
hearing a joke that they didn't like but
there'd be some people who would say
that telling a joke that didn't go over
well was the worst thing that happened
to them so I think think that you know
we need to relax a little bit if the way
we're handling it is stricter than
Leviticus okay I think that's fair uh
Ali I have to congratulate you on making
it on to Gutfeld although this is like
getting hired on Roseanne after Roseanne
left
yeah
welcome to the uh welcome to the Connors
social media is forcing the hand of some
comics and that they're playing along
with censorship because they want to
Brand well to bigger name comics in
Hollywood who might like put them on a
show or something yeah apps absolutely I
think it's more
more I think that these platforms will
actually prevent them from getting
the language
if they you know talk about certain
subjects so yeah they're definitely
playing to that okay and the bigger
names anyone who can get them anywhere
they're going to kiss up to you is that
what's going on so is that your strategy
I mean it's like no I'd be way further
ahead if that were my strategy I've
taken that strategy you wouldn't be on
the Connors you'd be on real Roseanne
yeah exactly uh Molly am I just like a
cranky old man uh who needs to step
aside for younger comedians like AOC
that would she is she's delightful I
love her
um but that's actually one of the things
that's so problematic for me as a comedy
viewer or listener is it's so boring now
like all of the safety makes for really
unfunny shows and um but I do it makes
me a little bit optimistic too that this
um this horrible moment of speech
policing that we're in makes really good
comedy kind of go underground and more
subversive and more it's like a
speakeasy exactly it's like The
Untouchables but instead of whiskey they
have like an open mic you know that's
funny well I would say this you can feel
there's like a cultural tide shifting in
the country in that we've identified the
outrage mob by number like in the
beginning of social media I don't think
we knew how many of them there were so a
lot of times we were getting them their
way now that you realize it's like three
guys one blow up doll and a cat you know
I think Comics are willing to give the
finger now like cat would you say Dave
Chappelle defunded the joke police by
standing up I think it's yeah I think
because he can it's really can't cancel
somebody who's that rich yeah yeah but
they they are really loud and they'd say
things like when they do say something
like words or violence then that shuts
down the conversation because if you try
to defend yourself at all then that's
just more proof in their minds that
they're right and I really think that
that's it's it is we all know that it's
such a small number of people that feel
this way but everybody a lot of us are
just too afraid of being canceled to
actually say I don't think that that's
you know that errant comment is a
summation of this entire person not just
as a bad person but as an irredeemable
person who's not welcome in society
anymore it's ridiculous yeah I think
that part's exhausting it's like we're
all running like a a law firm in our
head now you know where you have to vet
every thought that comes out of your
face and stuff like you're planning taco
night but you might get yelled at for
cultural appropriation don't you think
we're just tired also who can keep track
of which words you can and can't use
anymore people come out with these lists
that are absurd it's like you can't use
words like mother anymore and you're you
know home like what do I call you it's
oh it's crazy it's gotten to a point
where you know Ivy League colleges are
putting out lists of words that you have
to really think hard to figure out why
they're even Banning them I mean it's
crazy it's a weird time to be alive but
is that a sign then Chadwick because the
Oscars have started to like pivot back
towards like mainstream America okay
there was some like little Jimmy Kimmel
stuff where he took some shots but there
was also like an acknowledgment that Top
Gun made a lot of money right and like
straight white people went to see it
straight gay people but more importantly
people who love America went to see it
so are the Oscars at least getting the
message that they've kind of overstepped
their bounds in terms of like bashing
America uh well
was a good line by the way
day for you I am here to compliment you
I'm like your main hoe oh Chadwick
rotten girl yeah I guess but at the same
time it's like okay when Trump was
President not only Hollywood comedy the
news media anyone you think of went
totally insane scorched Earth ruined
everything yes went totally nuts and now
that they have Biden their little
placated okay but as soon as another
Republican gets it off it's gonna be the
same thing you think it's coming
Hollywood yeah yeah I think like now
they're like okay now we can have the uh
the American loving straight white male
movie uh-huh but if Trump gets back in
office no way so you're telling me I
have to watch an all-female Top Gun if
Trump wins re-election well hopefully
like the female Ghostbusters yeah
um but Molly would you make an argument
as someone who consumes comedy that Joe
Biden's kind of wearing us out because
he does so many stupid things there's no
shelf life
the idea that you could not make fun of
this person I know this vice president
or you know the entire Democrat Party
you have to be a failure to not be able
to go after these I mean think about
this he shot down someone's high school
science project
you really think about that as a people
when we were kids the most absurd excuse
you could ever give someone was the dog
ate my homework someone walked into an
American classroom two weeks ago and was
like the president shot down my balloon
you know and the teacher was like holy
hell he's right oh my God so that's the
part I think they're missing is like
it's this golden age it's like such
fertile comedy and I don't think we're
mining it for any value I know we're
mining it for Percocet in The Green Room
alley well that's the most important
that's what we need I uh I don't know
why people aren't making fun of them or
it's like they make fun of themselves
that's the problem it's almost so easy
that people don't want to do it you know
Biden's falling upstairs
likes Biden are you guys Pro bite it a
little bit you're like lay off Joe he's
a nice guy did you guys agree with Biden
at the State of the Union when he said
we have to choose between unity and
schmuck do you know that yes it was like
and I agreed with him on Unity but what
are schmagenaha was the right way to go
am I right I feel like we missed an
opportunity anyway before we go uh come
out and catch me on tour I'm going to be
in Bend Oregon on April the 7th Boise
Idaho on the 8th and I'll swing by
bananas in East Rutherford New Jersey
April 21st 22nd and then Kennedy and I
are in Reading Pennsylvania on May 6th
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else